is it possible to
make a soundtrack using a cucumber
inspired by this friendly fellow that
commented on my previous seeing sounds i
bet you can't make
gabby feel good with a cucumber you
irrelevant toss i was immediately drawn
to this one because of the idea of
ultimate clickbait potential
gabs
[Music]
bit beyond misspelling my flawless
wife's name
and undermining my intention to ensure
that she only ever feels good
i'm gonna tackle this one head on to
finally investigate the uncertain yet
optimistic belief that it's not about
the size of your cucumber that matters
it's rather about the way in which you
use it
now cucumbers come in all shapes and
sizes
[Music]
so i'm going to make use of all of these
to tickle gabby's fancy
and ultimately make her feel good by
recreating the timeless classic feel
good song by james brown
i feel good here's a quick non-technical
explanation
of how i turn these cucumbers into
musical instruments
[Music]
and two cute crumpets that's a cucumber
and
trumpet i tried getting them into key
of some sort but they kind of work this
cucumber being a
lower frequency just a simple sound here
this cucumber is a little bit more out
of tune but yeah
it works
surprisingly quite a diverse group of
percussive sounds
underneath that kick drum i'm going to
do a bit of cheetah
more deep trying to be truthful here
a bass guitar very simply made d g and a
and since it was referred to as an
irrelevant toss
i just made this irrelevant pit rock
that i'm just gonna toss around at
random objects
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
so good so good
oh wait [ __ ] i forgot about gaps god
what's going on just come stand here
right there
you're gonna blow on this
okay no no no like this
okay two three four
so good so good
[Music]
so good so good
[Music]
ready
you feel good yes so good and on that
note
i'm going to sign the seeing sounds out
love you
bye once again a hell of a lot of fun
thank you so much for the suggestions
all the
weird and just crazy suggestions in the
comments please keep them coming
and if you're looking for some creative
inspiration go and read the comments
trust me they are just
all kinds in there please subscribe and
turn on your notifications below
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and
i'll see you next week
[Music]